hello folks and welcome to rational
science
the only site on the internet that does
physics right
do the other sides do physics wrong
uh no
what they do is um they do physics
irrationally
they start moving concepts around like
field
and wave and zero dimensional particles
singularities or whatever
not in physics
anyways we divide our
lecture in three parts
we do extinction first because i hold
this site right
that in this channel that you we are the
last humans on earth the last generation
of humans on earth
when we're going to become extinct i
can't tell you but all i can tell you
it's imminent it's going to happen
soon
whatever that means to you i'm not a
an astrologer i can't give you a date
i'm just saying i can only give you the
mechanism and through the mechanism you
should infer that it's going to happen
soon
okay that's the point
anyways we do extinction first we do
physics
next and i'm going to be talking about
reflection today
what the hell is reflection we'll find
out
and then i'll um answer questions that
people have asked since last time okay
okay so let's get on with it uh we start
today with comments someone made
okay and it's got to do with the fact
that the other day i had an interview
with edward dutton
he's got a channel and we had a little
interview deba slash debate okay and so
that's what this comment is about that's
a good place to start today
says you talk past each other yeah okay
and i would say it was almost entirely
your fault
you didn't present any convincing
argument for your point of view in
particular regarding collapse of the
genetic diversity
and he continues says dutton's assertion
of the increase of the genetic diversity
mostly harmful is on full display every
day all around us for everyone to see
your example of how the chimpanzees are
more genetically diverse than people has
no weight
it is a static comparison and it doesn't
say anything about rate of change
what is he referring to real quick uh
he's referring to this article that i
put up
and that it says that a troop of
chimpanzees okay
uh maybe 100 individuals
probably no more than that maybe 150 at
most i would say are have more genetic
diversity than 8 billion people of the
human
race okay listen to that there's more
genetic diversity among these chimps
than there is throughout uh the human
race all humans
okay we have that there are differences
between one human and another but in
general compared to the chimps we are
all clones of each other that's the
point okay
and so um
this was
this is what this fellow is referring to
he says uh this is just a static point
it's not a rate
and he's he's correct it's not a rate
we're not talking about a rate we're
we're talking about the fact that
uh humans are not genetically diverse
and for that you don't need to know
anything about a rate okay so that's the
first issue but i want to address that
other issue that he raises that
could have been my fault
it's always to some degree
the
fault of the
interviewee okay
but there's also a problem with the
interviewer and the issue is as follows
uh first of all i want you to know i
sent ed dutton
about 10 graphs
and they were all related to the subject
matter that we were going to cover
and that was mass extinction
specifically the extinction of humans
that was what the talk was supposed to
be about well
if you look at the video those of you
who have seen it already we'll find that
no graph was ever shown
and then the second issue is that and
this happens uh i can't blame him for it
uh
it's it's partly my fault his fault both
i guess it doesn't really matter whose
fault it is the point is we drifted into
genetic
genetics specifically genetic diversity
and that wasn't the subject i was going
to cover okay
i was going to
cover the extinction of humans and that
really is unrelated uh at least as far
as humans per se are concerned uh with
genetic diversity it has to do with
economic collapse
so uh we never got to talk very deeply
about the subject matter that i was
scheduled to talk about
uh he didn't show any graphs that i put
up there which would have maybe
uh
allowed us to follow through the
reasoning okay none of that will happen
what happened is we drifted into genetic
diversity and let me tell you why or one
of the reasons why a very important
reason
everybody today is an expert on genetics
why because we're bombarded with this
information daily
okay everywhere you read uh the
geneticists have taken over
the world
uh on calling the shots on genetics
and i talked about that i think a couple
weeks ago or one week ago and this is
the it has to do with this human genome
project okay it started in in the 1990s
and as you can see it says the genomic
and they talk about an expanding
genomics industry
and how many billions have been invested
how many have been
uh
reaped okay and so on um
it's more or less like this health issue
everybody's a doctor today because uh
all you do is go under the internet
google it yahoo it whatever and you get
the information you have it at the tip
of your uh
at your fingertips you know and uh and
so people
form these opinions based on
what they read and there's a lot of
information out there so they can tell
you you know you shouldn't eat meat
because of this and you should i don't
know eat fruits or veggies or whatever
everybody's an expert and likewise
everybody's an expert in genetics
because there's so much information out
there and everybody reads a little bit
here and there and informs their
opinions
what's the problem the problem with
genetics
just like with mathematical physics is
that there are no competing theories
okay
either they're not allowed
they're censored
or for some reason they don't get on the
books you don't see them on the internet
so here comes a guy like me who's got a
different version of genetics
and you know of course you won't see my
theory out there ever
and people say well bill you don't
deserve to have your theory out there
this is not a question of raising your
hand
it's a question putting the theories out
there so that they compete and everybody
reaches his own conclusion
that's the way science should work
that's not the way science works and it
works it doesn't work that way because
there are too many interests
okay that's the problem too many
interests if if i have a theory that
goes against these guys and a lot of
people start believing this theory well
these guys lose their job their careers
their fame
okay
and so it's a big problem and again so
the problem is competing theories that's
the issue
and here you know this guy already made
up his mind he made up his mind that uh
you know that uh he says the assertion
of the increase of genetic diversity
is full display every day he says he's
he's
proved it to himself so he doesn't budge
from that line of thinking
and yeah comes a guy like me and says
look we're losing genetic diversity
what are you talking about bill you're
going against the grain we've already
proven that
have we
have we proven that we gain genetic
diversity and they say yeah see the
mutation rate happens every day for
different people we're 8 billion people
so that's got to be increasing
okay so um
let's find out where this goes
here we have a
fellow who more or less
answers
that with another comment okay and this
all says this is your main point
referring to the same thing okay it says
uh which is well known among ecologists
and i guess you would say geneticists
and paleontologists as well you would
include those as well as an endangered
species dwindles okay it loses genetic
variation
and even if the species rebounds its
level of genetic variation will not
and then he says something which i
highlighted there which i think is very
important to
keep here in this context
genetic variation will only slowly be
restored through the accumulation of
mutations over many generations
keep that last statement in mind okay it
takes several generations to recover
genetic variation okay takes a long time
okay um so the first criticism i have
here the that wasn't my main point in
fact he's got it in reverse
i propose something that no one has
proposed to this date
not a single geneticist not a single
paleontologist biologist
uh geologist none of these people have
proposed today
and that is the exact opposite of what
he's saying there i'm not talking about
endangered species
an endangered species is one that is in
the last throws
you know uh
10 individuals that's an endangered
species 100 individual maybe at most 200
then they say oh this is an endangered
species we we humans need to protect it
and yeah when you have only 100 200
maybe 10
of a given
species
then yeah you can say that
the
genetic diversity
or variation dwindles
okay
i'm saying exactly the opposite
i'm seeing a species that expands uh
demographically
loses genetic diversity we're not
talking about an endangered species
we're talking about the exact opposite
one that expands
demographically it loses genetic
diversity that's what i'm saying
now you don't have to agree with me okay
i'm not here to
twist your arm i'm just saying that's
what i'm saying and i'm saying that no
one has ever proposed that on planet
earth
okay so let's get that straight up front
now you say well bill you're crazy
how can you be saying
that
a species that is expanding it has all
these mutations it accumulates them
right over time
and
you would think that
you know there should be more genetic
diversity
uh-huh let's find out this is the um
graph that i've got and i didn't not
again send this to ed dutton because i
wasn't going to talk about genetics okay
i was going to talk about mass
extinction okay here is the graph i
showed it last time and it's that
after a species more or less uh settles
in an area it's uh already branched out
from its main group that's how a species
is created it can only lose genetic
diversity why because you have
population bottlenecks specifically
diseases
and uh then you know when you chop a big
branch or a very significant group of
the
population uh what you're left is with
this founder effect that means that now
you have fewer individuals from where
you're going to draw the next set of
genetics
of you know you're going to increase
your variation in genetics
and what does this guy say let me put
that back up here again
okay this guy said
genetic variation will only slowly be
restored to the accumulation of
mutations over what many generations
so here's uh this poor species it's
trying to create this genetic diversity
little by little and then mother nature
comes in there with a big huge disease
and kills half of them
well it doesn't matter how much they
accumulated if mother nature is going to
wipe out half their population
it doesn't really work that way okay but
uh what i'm referring to here let me get
back in here
what i'm referring to here is that um
in the case of humans for example we
have a little bit of history on that so
we can extrapolate that to other animals
as well
and the way it works with humans
half of the children before the age of
five would die
all the way until the beginning of the
20th century
well
really i'm sorry i'll correct that uh
beginning of the 19th century so for 200
220 years
we stopped that process until then half
the children before the age of five
would die
okay
now imagine that for any species of
animals
including you can include plants as well
when they start out um
if half
of the offspring of any species dies
when they're just coming out
okay
and they could be dying primarily of
diseases because they're not used to
these diseases so maybe
uh just to use the human numbers before
the age of five for whatever species you
know comparable to humans you know
before the age of five if if they die if
half of them die then you can see that
the population doesn't really expand
very fast because a lot of them are
dying they could die because a predator
falls on them you know on top of them
kills them they could die because
there's a disease
and so it's a very slow growth for many
many thousands of years
until they finally get used to at least
the endemic diseases and learn how to
fight off some of the predators maybe
they learn to
run faster maybe they develop horns to
be able to
counter attack or whatever so there's
this arm race going on
uh and so the the issue here is that
a lot of the children
die
throughout most of a species uh history
that's the typical curve okay and i
showed that curve the
curve of life and so the issue here is
that
you're chopping off a lot of diversity
and only allowing this tiny mutation
that's happening over
centuries
which you can kill in one second by
wiping out either through this process
killing babies or chopping off a big
portion of the population because
suddenly a disease came in and killed
half the population or whatever
so yes it's much stronger
uh the
mechanism of killing then is the
mutation rate
okay that's essentially why i say that
genetic diversity can only decline and
every time a disease comes and kills
half the population all you've done is
streamline the genetic pool
okay you have fewer from i mean just
pick a number you know you got a
thousand individuals you wipe out 500 of
them
now you have only 500 from which to draw
the next generation you know the
founders effect
so they start accumulating some of the
genetic diversity that was lost with the
with their pals that died
and then another big hit comes another
disease or they move into a different
area or they have a new predator or or
whatever there's there's a you know uh
the jungle out there is very dangerous
and and again big chop
lost an arm you know now you gotta
restart the whole thing all over again
so i'm saying that over time mutations
will not recover
what you lose through
bottlenecks population bottlenecks and
founders effect primarily carried out by
disease takes many centuries many
thousands of years for a species to
adapt
to diseases and so that the disease
becomes endemic
once it becomes endemic it's no longer
such a killer
in the new generation the
the generation can withstand it maybe
some get sick but they don't die anymore
at some point they become completely
immune
to it okay so this is this is my
argument okay
okay so yeah this fellow
has a problem he says i do get the idea
of bottlenecks and founder effects which
i do not know if they are more important
than the mutations over time
so how is how is he going to prove it
is he going to wait a million years to
be able to collect information on on
this and say oh yeah i finally proved it
because through observation i was able
to tell that
you know that founders effect and
bottlenecks overcome
the
gradual mutations that we can have in
our species
and now add to that
uh inbreeding
humans have been in breeding for two
hundred thousand three hundred thousand
years
what i mean by that is that if you go
back in time
the the one you can still consider
someone from your own species
is if you can have viable children with
that person
and if you go back 500 000 years you
probably wouldn't be able to have viable
children fertile children
you probably can go as far back as maybe
200 300 000 years this is an assumption
okay
you heard the
mitochondrial eve she's 200 000 years
old that's more or less uh
where i'm coming from those are the
assumptions that i make from which by
part okay so you don't have to agree
with them i'm just saying that's where i
start i'm i think that's a pretty good
number and i don't think we could go
beyond 200 300 000 years and still have
viable children with whoever our
ancestor was in those days okay as ever
in fact the guy was probably in africa
and was coming out and here we've
covered the planet so we've been in
different environments we had different
diseases
diseases that would kill that individual
that do not kill us today
okay
so that's more or less my reasoning on
that
um
this fellow says uh
also he brings this issue up
he says there is no intrinsic
disadvantage to inbreeding
i like that
uh so so we can inbreed you can sleep
with your sister and you'll be okay okay
that's what he's saying it is totally
solely statistically inbreeding done
right purchase the bad alleles out of
the gene pool you know genetic purging
all it does is revealing the defects it
does not create them okay on the other
hand there are intrinsic mechanisms of
outbreathing depressions where it does
create defects solely by itself
so he's saying that when you
marry externally
uh you can run into trouble because you
don't know what you're getting on the
other hand if you marry internally
there's nothing
intrinsically wrong with that okay
that's what he's saying that's his
argument and similarly and he gives an
example of icelandic studies have shown
that third generation cousins you know
if they marry they were okay
uh et cetera et cetera okay
okay i think we've got a problem here
this uh
again if you talk about
what we have out there the record you
would say that this guy is completely
wrong he's he's got it upside down okay
yeah inbreeding is a serious problem
that's why we don't do it okay and
here's i gave you example the other day
of the
kings of spain there charles ii was
great great great uh
grandson of charles the first and he's
got that habsburg chin
and he was known as el ecisado the
bewitched because he was sick throughout
his uh life
everybody was waiting for him to die
from day one and he lived 39 years until
he finally died and we all know the case
or a lot of us know the case of the
ramanas
and uh they and bread inbred and
because of that uh you know they passed
on this uh
chromosome which allowed them to be nine
of them in fact in the uh in the whole
um family since victoria which was their
uh
great grandmother
uh had nine of them had hemophilia and
among them alexey romanoff and then we
know the case of the amish they've been
around for 300 years they started with
500 settlers approximately
and today there's like 330 000 of them
and what do you see now well you see six
finger kids okay among other big
problems they have cohen's disease and
who knows what they've got a lot of
genetic problems why because they've
been inbreeding and so no inbreeding is
not good as this gentleman says totally
wrong
and then at the bottom there right
you'll see that if if we were around for
maybe 200 to 300 000 years ago those who
were on our ancestors the ones you see
there we've been in breeding for 200 300
000 years and so you should not be
surprised that today we have all kinds
of serious
problems we're having more and more uh
people uh be born with two heads for
example with siamese
twins uh kind of thing
and you say well we've always had those
uh uh
absolutely not
the first one dates to i don't remember
the date exactly but the first recorded
case was uh if i got it right i think
it's 1200
sometime around the
13th century
and why do i think that's the first case
well because no one documented a case
before then you would have thought that
if the greeks the romans the persians
you know people who wrote stuff that we
see today
uh if they would have seen a kid with
two heads alive you know like living
walking around
i think a lot of people would have
noticed that you know someone would have
written something
about that kid
or that pair of kids
and we don't have that uh the first case
recorded case if i've got a i've had the
exact date somewhere but i should have
brought that today but
i've got to correct the uh the first
case with a pair of girls
and i think it dates to the 13th century
which means that
this is a uh it didn't happen 200 000
years ago this is something new it's got
to do with inbreeding and i'm going to
go a step further and say that a lot of
the autism that we see today among
humans homosexuality and all its
variants you know all that is related to
inbreeding
yeah that's my take on that you don't
have to agree again
i'm just giving you my version of that
okay and um here
we find an article in the wikipedia and
just in case it reinforces what i just
said inbreeding results in more
recessive traits manifesting themselves
uh as the genomes of pair mates are more
similar recessive traits can only occur
in an offspring
if present in both parents genomes the
more genetically similar the parents are
the more often recessive traits appear
in their offspring in other words if the
parents are brother and sister well
there you have it you know you're going
to have recessive traits
consequently the more closely related
the breeding pair is the more homozygous
deleterious genes the offspring may have
resulting in very unfit individuals the
fitness of homozygous
recessive state may even be zero
meaning
sterile or unviable offspring
so is uh inbreeding a problem well i
would say it is okay
i don't think you uh want to marry your
sister
and if you marry your sister
do it only once because if you marry
your sister and then your kids they
marry and then their kids marry
well we got a serious problem on the
third fourth generation you know you're
gonna have some kind of problem
and that's what's happened to the amish
and that's what would happen if a pocket
of humans survives the holocaust the
economic collapse that i'm saying is
imminent
if a group of people survive let's say a
family survives and there's 10 to 15 or
20 individuals
within which we have only a small
percentage maybe one-third of them that
can reproduce
and they're too closely related already
and that's one issue
we don't even have genetic diversity
among the whole human race but imagine
brother and sister or cousins marrying
okay so they have a kid and the other
guy has a kid and they're all from the
same family well uh next generation they
have a kid and they come from the same
uh founders okay founder effect
well what do you think is going to
happen to third or fourth or fifth
generation
well they're gonna have
six fingers you know they're gonna gray
grow some weird stuff
among
the issue that they might come mentally
defective and so even if some a pocket
survives and they decide to have
children
who decide to have children who decide
to have children that's not going to be
viable at some point it's going to crash
anyways
so that's the end of humanity one way or
the other
okay
so now you know my argument okay you
don't have to believe it and i'm here
just to give you my side of the story
okay another issue that was raised by
this uh by one of these fellows uh
channel island foxes have 99.9 hamas
egocity okay
they uh yet they have remained at small
population sizes with low diversity for
many generations but they also have an
absence of inbreeding depression and
saying confirming that they are not
afflicted with congenital defects common
to other small and inbred populations
when you look it up in the wikipedia you
find exactly the contrary it says renee
valen with an archaeologist believes
that inbreeding depression among these
foxes okay
can be managed by mixing different
island fox subspecies populations moving
them to different islands
so yes they do according to this
individual you know have inbreeding
depression
so all i can tell you is um you may have
your facts wrong again okay
uh
what can i say do a little more research
okay
we don't see eye to eye
[Laughter]
okay uh let me move on here
um
okay
this is the issue the issue is that
you know i don't trust geneticists any
further than i can throw them i don't
trust paleontologists any further than i
can throw them why
uh neither one especially paleontologist
since uh this
discipline was invented uh maybe 200 220
years ago
not one can explain extinction to you
they cannot tell you how a mass
extinction happens they cannot tell you
how one species disappears
and the main issue there is that they
have to answer is
selectivity
if you cannot
answer why or how mother nature isolates
one species
or a group in order of species whether
plants or animals if you cannot explain
that process
for land
sea and air
okay
you don't have a theory of extinction if
you don't have a theory of extinction
you are not a paleontologist because a
paleontologist his only job
is to explain extinction
once we have an explanation for
extinction we're done
with paleontology they can continue
dusting bones and assembling them for a
museum that's not paleontology that's
stamp collecting
paleontologists has only one job as a
scientist and that is to explain
extinction and in 200 years no one has
been able to explain extinction
how do they explain it well they do it
ad hoc
they create one
mechanism
for each
little thing that they want to explain
so for example the famous cretaceous
extinction
they say well there was this uh asteroid
that hit the earth fine did that kill
all the animals absolutely not
so they say well what happened was you
know there was this great explosion many
tnt many nuclear bombs etc they give you
this picture
and all this debris went up in the air
okay so now they say well you know now
um it covered the whole earth it did not
allow photosynthesis
so all plants died okay
let's concede that how did the mammals
survive well they did fruitis
okay so how did the fish in the seas die
or you know whatever animals were in the
seas and they say well see it turns out
that the asteroid just happened to hit a
pile of sulfur
and because of that you know sulfur
acidified the waters and some animals
could take it and others could
so they have to invent
all these different mechanisms who say
well why is this one survive what did
why that when why was that one killed
okay
and what they cannot explain
specifically at least for the cretaceous
really for none of the mass extinctions
is
chronological
selectivity
why is it that always the old
and big species die
and the little guys who radiate
afterwards why did they survive it's
always the old and big
mother nature is uh very careful in
her selectivity it's not only
selectivity between species it's
chronological selectivity
so that's what you gotta answer if you
can't answer that question you're not a
paleontologist all you are is uh a stem
collector you dust bones and put them in
a museum okay
so here i have a case uh one that no
paleontologist can explain came out last
year i think november of last year okay
it says madagascar okay so because
madagascar has lots of variety of uh
animals that exist nowhere else in the
world it's probably
the
concentration of most species that no
one else has okay like 80 percent of the
species there exists nowhere else in the
world
so saw a relatively recent mass
extinction event about a thousand years
ago okay
and when gorilla sighs lemurs uh
uh towering elephant birds and grand
tortoises uh were were all wiped out
from the island okay so
these big animals
were wiped out okay a recently published
paper complicates the wildly widely held
understanding that humans were to blame
for the crash
by drawing attention to the mega drought
dry land okay no no rain that the
authors say played a role okay the
growing consensus that the earth is in
the throes of a sixth mass extinction
has focused attention on a centuries-old
ecological puzzle
why do species suddenly disappear by the
droves
yeah why
see these people cannot explain mass
extinction that's the
point and they have these theories but
the theories are not selective you
cannot explain why this guy died not the
other guy died
and we've been this with this for 200
years and all they do is repeat the same
theories over and over
again okay so it's an asteroid climate
change uh you've heard all these already
i don't have to repeat them volcanoes
you know or plumes coming out of the
ground what is it methane
covering the earth
forbidding uh photosynthesis or creating
a uh
what is called as an impact winter or
nuclear winter you know
it's always the same stuff and you
cannot explain selectivity with any of
those mechanisms with catastrophes
okay
so this is the issue the issue is that
they cannot explain and they just keep
going and they just say
we're going to look for more information
you don't need any more information you
got all the information you need you
need a theory that's what you need
and right now we don't have theories
okay we don't have an explanation
of how this happens
okay uh and so
what i can tell you is uh
a lot of this has to do
with
how old a species is why did these
animals disappear
well they disappeared because they were
old species
now you know you're
a human
is born as you know a little baby
and expands expands expands becomes a
boy but boy or a girl uh then uh goes
through puberty and grows continues
growing maybe to the age of 20 25
whatever and then at some point turns
the corner going becomes old wrinkled
like me
i'm approaching 70 okay and uh what
happens at that point well at some point
you die
you turn the corner you die
very simple
how about a species
does a species grow
old
how can you tell if a species is old
are humans old
maybe we're an old species
and people say no we're not an old
species we've been around what two
hundred thousand years
and again the dinos has been around for
two million years or you know some of
them like the t-rex apparently have been
around for only the last two million
years before that there were other
dinosaurs
so hold it the dinos the t-rexes at
least they were the apex predator and
they were around for two million years
and mother nature only gave us 200 000
years and we're going to become extinct
now
come on bill what are you talking about
well all i can tell you is humans are a
very old species not according to how
many times the earth went around the sun
humans are an old species according to
mother nature's rules
okay
and all i can show you is what those uh
rules are okay
here they are
these are my take on those rules if i
can get this thing up there how to tell
if uh whether species is old okay
low reproductive rate
okay
long lives
we live long lives we're one of the big
animals that lives the longest okay
maybe turtles beat us maybe some other
animal out there in general we're among
the top
honchos in in that category
we're immune to natural diseases in in
the wild okay
so um
you know uh
we don't die of diseases anymore today
we have genetic problems
uh old age at some point
uh you know um
you cannot live forever for whatever
reason right and so we die of heart
ailments and circulate circulatory
problems we don't die of smallpox
anymore which has been eradicated we
don't die from the childhood diseases
anymore again
50 of the children under the age of five
would die from childhood diseases people
200 years ago saw death every day
they had a neighbor who was pregnant and
the baby came out wrong or uh was
immediately attacked by one of the
childhood diseases and that was it
and one of the two either through
vaccines for those of you who believe in
vaccines or through natural selection
right
um those who could not resist these
diseases died and those who could
gave birth to
us
that's why we are all clones today
because we went through the same sifting
process whether you're japanese you're
african you're russian you're south
american or north american it doesn't
matter our forefathers went through the
same sifting process of diseases we had
better all be more or less the same
none of us die of these childhood
diseases anymore you know a couple
people here in the on the planet that's
it it's it doesn't kill us anymore by
the millions like it used to
okay so let's get all that right
and uh sedentary we don't migrate
anymore you know the last time we
migrated i think was when
columbus discovered america and shortly
after that was it
and now we've conquered all the
continents i don't think there's another
continent out there but let me know okay
if i'm wrong
so we've conquered all the continents
and what's worse
is we didn't have to adapt to many
things in those continents except
disease okay climate we adapt very
easily we put a coat on if it's cold we
take it off when it's hot
so we
do not have to force our bodies to make
any adjustments
to
environmental uh
changes
because we we have all these artificial
ways of protecting ourselves from
extremes
so if you go to the north pole you don't
go nude like you would be in the equator
no you put the coat on at least
the rust can be nude
and uh copela we're large we're among
the largest mammals
on earth
okay
and among the largest mammals um sorry
uh hominids in our la in our dynasty if
you go you know you've seen the
the little chart where you go from
monkey to mother man
it's always from small to big we've
grown over time in size
so those are the five criteria to know
if a species is old and we meet all five
of them
we are an old species by those standards
and the reason we got old we conquered
diseases very quickly because our
populations expanded we
migrated very fast across the planet
and
with technology helped us adapt to many
things among them better living
conditions cleaner conditions and so on
so so you know diseases don't kill us
anymore we don't have to fight diseases
anymore our great grandfathers did that
okay so we don't have to worry about all
that anymore
and so yeah we're an old species
and i'm saying this is um
this is what happened to
some of those animals probably on
madagascar island
they were probably an old species they
were around for a long time
and uh that's probably what happened to
them so when one went out and the
predator who prayed on that herbivore
maybe went out as well and so on you
know they probably went uh
extinct
one right after another and
approximately at the same time
geological time maybe within a hundred
years okay
okay um
here is just uh
another
vision of that okay that you want to
ponder
uh i say that um the
what is it these parrots and um
the macaws and the sequoias i'm saying
these are old species okay and here we
read a couple of people who studied
these things and they can't figure out
certain things which they would have
been able to figure out if they knew
what an old species is
says we suggest the extreme longevity in
parrots has evolved in response to
species specific characteristics of diet
habitat and behavior
another one says uh
viability of the sequoia seed is low
typically well below 50 in 15 so that
means that they have very little
reproduction right the low viability may
be an adaptation to discourage seed
predators no they don't realize that
these trees just like the the macaws air
are very old animals they are sedentary
they don't migrate they have very few
children they're big they have all the
diseases of old age okay so that's why
these um
uh
trees and uh and animals here this bird
that's why they have all these problems
or that's why they have all these
characteristics okay and there at the
bottom you see
a couple papers that have been done
in quite a bit of detail says increased
reproductive effort has been found to be
associated with a considerable reduction
in what longevity in a number of
organisms they mentioned a couple and
but they reached the wrong conclusion
you say because they say the cost of
reproduction might in part result from a
trade-off in the allocation of resources
between fecundity and body maintenance
or growth no absolutely not it's what
they're talking about what they're
looking at is old species that's what
they're looking at
okay and again you have to find out what
an old species is you have to find out
if species can grow old
and i'm saying again
old species one that has lost genetic
diversity so you can tell how old the
species is by looking at how much
diversity is and it's not all right like
this first guy said no it's a
cross-section you look at what the
diversity is if it's very little
diversity compared to other animals then
that one's an old species that's one
issue the other issue is that all
mammals all mammals have been around for
a long time so all mammals have lost
almost their entire genetic diversity
some more than others
some are ahead some are a little behind
but
all mammals
have lost their genetic diversity if we
went back in time 200 000 years ago we
would find more genetic diversity among
mammals than we find today that's my
argument okay
and i'm saying genetic diversity is a
measure of how long a given species has
been on the planet okay that's my
argument
take it or leave it okay
okay let's move on fella says many women
today do the natural birthing method
usually in a river because i'm saying
that you know the ladies tomorrow if
there's a group that survives okay
uh the economy collapse
uh women will not have
children
and you say why won't we start the race
again like adam and eve you know start
reproducing and procreating again
i'm saying no for many reasons first of
all there's a psychological issue you
hear the whole world has collapsed
you're the last family on earth
you know you're not going to start
having babies because you've got a
psychological impact you know what
happened
that's one issue but but then there's uh
this issue that this fellow raises and
that's that
he thinks that women are going to have
babies in the in the river
women first there's tempting women on
the planet that have babies in the water
you know very few women do that great
majority of women go to a hospital and
they want to have the best care possible
because if they need a cesarean they
want a doctor to be there with a you
know with a little knife opening them up
and and putting anesthesia and all this
good stuff
you know when the global collapse
happens there won't be any of that there
won't be any doctors
and this woman yeah you can say she can
have it in the river yeah you think
she's gonna risk that especially a city
girl of today
we're not talking about women uh
200 300 years ago we're talking to women
of today from the city they don't have
babies let alone have babies in the
river but even if they decide to have a
baby in the river it's a big risk for
her aside from the fact that she's
needed for the
subsistence
uh agriculture of that society we're
talking about 10 15 people
and she's going to have the last
children a child on earth
with her brother
for what
so no no uh having in the river doesn't
change anything okay and again women
don't have children in the river 99 of
them don't there's a lot of women that
do out there you know who knows how many
but most women just go to the doctor and
they want to be on the safe side that's
the reality especially city girls you
know country girls they might still do
that and some do it in the bathtub you
know because that's what they want to do
that's what they learned that's what
they saw on google and they said well i
think i'm going to risk it i'm going to
go to the bathtub but the great majority
go go to a hospital okay
okay another fellow says the common says
80 of the population wouldn't recognize
food growing out of the ground let alone
know what to do with it and he's totally
right i think a lot of these city people
especially those who do
what is it home office
i don't think they know what a potato is
like a potato plant looks like
uh in fact i didn't know until i started
growing my own potatoes then i learned
the difference between a potato uh plant
and a uh you know
watermelon plant you know then then you
finally find out the differences
otherwise you can't tell the difference
you you don't know i mean you know if
you've been in the city all your life
and uh yeah i think a lot of the kids
today they probably think that potato
chips grow on trees you know who knows
um
another fellow says something made me
laugh
nothing ever really went extinct
life finds a way plants and animals just
change after something like a pole
reversal or continental drift causing
the weather to change on whole
continents
uh yeah and you might say well
do people really believe this and yeah
you'll find people out there who
actually believe
that t-rex did not disappear uh he
turned into a bird
he grew wings at the last moment and
started flying around
he turned into by the condor that was a
t-rex
that's what they believed
so yeah all i can tell you is the
following you want to do extinction 101
before you do extinction 102 you want to
know how a mass extinction happens
before you talk about human extinction
unfortunately i didn't get to do that
with mr dutton
i had sent them some stuff and it would
have been great if we would have
followed the charts it would have been a
much more organized
discussion debate
but instead we drifted off into genetic
diversity which i haven't prepared
uh any graphs or anything to show so i
could not talk too much about genetic
diversity so yeah he's written this
fellow's right i did not make my case
because that wasn't supposed to be my
case my case was supposed to be about
mass extinction okay
and as far as the homework uh fella
answered that the other day so i don't
think i'm gonna put that back up again
unless
i just comment on it or whatever
why do animals on land die approximately
at the same time as animals in the seas
fell says that they more or less start
at the same time at the same starting
line and this is the graph okay just
want to show it one more time and that's
that
and again it's not that clear-cut and
i'll mention that in a second but you
know you have the seed ferns and the
friends in general they were for the era
known as the permian and triassic so
there you had 100 million years in which
these plants covered the land what came
after the conifers the gymnosperms uh
that's jurassic and cretaceous another
130
plus years okay and then and then today
since that time we've had the
angiosperms you know there's the
flowering plants okay and you can see
that it's getting shorter and shorter
and shorter okay the the
frequency right or the distance between
beginning and end and again some of
these plants it's not like uh the some
seed firms started uh 250 million years
ago and then died two 200 million years
ago 50 million years like there you see
in a triassic now what happened is a lot
of these tiny animals in the new plants
they started perhaps in the mid permian
and they worked their way outwards and
then suddenly the big guys died 250
million years ago and these other ones
were able to radiate and go into the
triassic
but they didn't start at 250 million
years ago they probably started 275
million years ago or thereabouts or even
earlier and they started expanding at
the expense of the ones that were dying
the older plants okay so
just keep that in mind it's um
it's it's the the history of life on
earth essentially so that's why when i
say that
you know um
the reason
animals on land die approximately at the
same time the animals in the seas um
essentially regurgitating
uh
the history of life on earth and that is
that when these guys died
right on a mass extinction what
continued were a radiation of smaller of
uh newer plants and smaller animals
which now begin to radiate and
become the
finance flora
of the next uh period
okay so that's essentially the theory
okay so let's move on to physics okay uh
what are we gonna do today we're gonna
do a reflection
uh have you reflected on reflection okay
um here we have mr
narcissus okay and he's a famous guy
from
greek mythology guy looks at himself
in the water it's perfect match there
it's straight forward okay he sees every
part of himself straight forward
and uh we call that a reflection
and they say that uh mr
narcissus you know he uh essentially
fell in love with himself
and
died
he turned into a
flower that's the
story okay
okay
so what do we have
i think i covered this also one time
before i'll just show it one more time
and that's that here you see
reflection if you put yourself in front
of a mirror
you can see that every
inch of you
and i'm sure that if you could go to the
atomic level we could even talk about
every atom in your body
is uh
is um
mirrored
to use the term uh directly in the
mirror in other words it's straight
ahead it's back and forth
how does mother nature do this magic
trick
are you shooting particles at the mirror
that are bouncing and coming back
i mean remember the earth moves around
the sun
so you know they should be all these
particles should be no matter how you
look it should be going as a curve right
especially when
general relativity says that gravity
pulls on light brings light down we were
able to measure that through the harvard
tower experiment remember that
and so we got a little bit of problem
because um according to general
relativity
light only
travels in curves
it can never travel in a straight line
and yet here you are in front of a
mirror you could swear that it's a
straight line
and yeah these guys will say well we
would have to measure that and we can't
measure that so we don't know
okay
let's find out let's find out uh if
that's even
possible to have a different conclusion
that um
you know that light travels straight or
really travels right to linearly
or extends straight okay that's the
correct language
okay uh here we have
uh an example okay ray reversibility and
again if you put a shadow light through
a prism or a
lens in this case
uh against the mirror light apparently
travels in the same direction along the
same path in the opposite direction
and i mean if it's straight ahead you
would say well you know it just hit and
came back but here you have the mirror
at an angle and yet again you can you
you can show to yourself that the mirror
will reflect it back through the
lens
uh back to if you had a
mirror there where you have the
flashlight
it would reflect it right back to it how
does uh mother nature do this trick with
particles
okay so this is the issue
and i
talked about this a little while ago
um
the lunar ranging experiment that nasa
and the russians have
done and here's the problem that uh
created that you create with light
traveling in curves according to
relativity you have a retro reflector on
the moon you're going to shoot a laser
at it right it's a little over a uh one
light second away uh two point four two
and a half light seconds round trip
and that's what's going to happen the
earth is going to move around the sun
the moon is going to move around the
earth so you've got a
a difference in in the time you send it
out and the time you receive it
and now you're going to have curvature
of space remember the earth weighs down
space time
so those little marbles those photon
marbles are going to roll down the uh
the curve the curvature of space time so
uh
how does that curvature get to the uh to
the retro reflector and back to you
you know you would think that the folks
out there the ones who work with this
are pointing the the laser directly at
the retro reflector in fact that's what
they do
they like i showed the other day
they have this crater
which is a something they can more or
less see from earth and they have the
retro reflector somewhere in there and
they know that if they point their laser
which is
has a diameter of like
anywhere from four to six
kilometers uh wide
uh you know they they know they're going
to hit the retro reflector
and they're going to have a signal come
back to them like you know a little
shining little thing and that comes to
their detector and they say okay there's
the reflector and we we know we hit it
it's not like they see it it's like they
uh shoot it and if they get a signal
back they say okay we hit it that's how
it works okay and what they're trying to
determine is how far the moon is and
whether it's flying farther out or
getting closer to earth that's the point
of the lane laser ranging experiment but
if you have the curvature of space or
space time then you got a little bit of
problem because all those marbles photon
marbles they're going to roll downwards
very steep by the way because the earth
is weighing down
space-time in order for the moon to go
around it like a little ball around the
roulette
now you have to have a depression which
is what they illustrate and and explain
and ill you know both so
you have the earth weighing down the
canvas right now the the little photon
balls they have to go through that same
curvature to reach the the moon whether
it's in one second or not it doesn't
matter they have to go through curvature
and so you're saying it goes through
curvature hits the retroreflector and
now the earth and the moon meanwhile
moved and that's going to come back
through that same curvature and hit the
earth hit the uh detector
yeah sure
again their explanation is with what's
irrational that's what i'm criticizing
okay
um
so here we have uh
uh mr feynman he's gonna explain to us
reflection okay fortunately he did a
good job on that and i hope you learned
reflection from him today okay all that
we know
uh mr feynman is perfect for that he was
a good teacher
good in the sense that he could teach
subject matter uh very nicely he was a
good ex
person who could
expose the theory
but the question is whether the theory
has
any rationality whatsoever
and we'll let mr feinman speak for
himself for for all of quantum mechanics
okay so the first thing he warns you
about he says people are always asking
for the latest developments in the
unification of this theory with that
theory and they don't give us the
mathematical physicist right a chance to
tell them anything about what we know
pretty well
so he wants to tell them something
but that's not what people ask what
people ask you what they ask in places
like quora
how does gravity work how does magnetism
work that's what people want to know
that's what they want to understand
that's what they want people like
feynman to explain and that's not what
they know that's not what they can
explain and that's not what they tell
them they say look we don't want to talk
about that
what do they want to talk about they
always want to know the things we don't
know
yeah i like that from uh feynman yeah uh
because he's not a physicist that's why
a physicist is a guy who can explain
what he cannot explain that's a
physicist otherwise he's a mathematician
just a petty mathematician who does what
what does mathematics do descriptions
that's all math can do math is a
descriptive language it's not a science
it has nothing to do with science or
with physics physics is not about math
physics is about explaining a mechanism
that's the difference and what these
people never were able to do in the last
hundred years since quantum mechanics at
least is explain
a mechanism
okay so this is the problem because
that's what people want to know about
reflection you look at yourself in the
mirror and you ask how does that work
how does how does that happen how does
mother nature do that magic trick and
these people say ask me a question that
i can answer
like
that's not one of them okay
okay so here's mr feiner he's going to
tell us everything he knows about
reflection here it is he says the
strange theory of light and matter qed
quantum electrodynamics
what i'd like to talk about is a part of
physics that is known rather than a part
that is unknown so he says this is known
okay okay what is it that they know i
would like to tell you about a subject
that has been thoroughly analyzed he
says attempts to understand the motion
of electrons going around the nucleus by
using mechanical laws
uh analogous to way the way uh newton
used the laws of motion to figure out
how the earth went around the sun were a
real failure
what is he talking about well he's
talking about this he's saying that we
cannot explain how an electron goes
around the nucleus and falls from one um
energy level or orbital to another and
comes back they cannot explain that not
with particles
and so they don't have a mech a
mechanical
explanation for this okay this is the
issue this is what he's saying here he
says attempt to understand the motion of
the electrons going around the nucleus
were a real
failure
okay we got that let's keep that in mind
he's telling us they don't know and he
cannot explain
what you want to know he's going to tell
you what he says they've proven and know
for a fact okay let's find out what it
is they they know
okay here is uh continues as the theory
of the interaction of light and matter
quantum electrodynamics was finally
developed in 1929
but the problem here is that he goes
through this and he says
first he says they proved it through
experiment and it all matches great okay
then he says i would like to again
impress with
you with the vast range of phenomena
that the theory quantum electrodynamics
what describes
he's not going to explain he's going to
describe and he says it's easier to say
it backwards the theory what describes
all the phenomena etcetera etcetera
etcetera he's going to talk about
descriptions he's not going to talk
about explanations and that's what we
want to know we want to know how
reflection works and he said well
i'm not going to answer that question
i'm going to tell you a description
okay and what's he going to describe
let's find out let's find out what mr
feynman the great finder is going to
describe for us
i must clarify something when i say that
all phenomena of the physical world can
be what explained by this theory we
don't really know that
these are his words okay i'm not putting
words in his mouth we have found nothing
wrong with the theory of quantum
electrodynamics it is therefore i would
say the jewel of physics our proudest
possession great great uh possession but
it turns out he says he's not going to
be able to explain it he doesn't really
know
that okay
okay he continues here he says uh will
you understand what i'm going to tell
you
you think i'm going to explain it to you
so you can understand it
no you're not going to be able to
understand it you see my physics
students don't understand it either that
is because i don't understand it nobody
does while i am describing what
explaining now describing to you how
nature works you won't understand why
now there is a mechanism nature works
that way but you see nobody understands
that i can't explain why nature behaves
in this peculiar way and right and the
reason he cannot explain it he cannot
explain with particles that's the
problem okay keep that in mind he cannot
explain it what with particles okay it
doesn't mean nature doesn't have a
mechanism it means that you cannot
explain that mechanism with particles
okay that's what i'm going to argue here
the theory of quantum electrodynamic uh
what describes nature as absurd from a
point of view of common sense now from a
point of view of particles that's where
the problem is if you try to do with
particles it's what he says there at the
end it's absurd
okay it agrees fully with experiment but
the explanation is absurd because he's
going to try to simulate it
with particles discrete particles that's
where the problem is okay
okay so he continues here and he says
says newton thought that light was made
up of particles he called them
corpuscles and he was right
oh my god here we have religion now
um mr feinman's not going to allow me to
present an alternative to that he says
he was right and you're wrong bill we're
done
okay this is how it works in so-called
science in so-called mathematical
physics what they do is they say it's
particles all the way and you have no
say
in it you can't give an alternative
version of this even today okay
we know i like that word we know they
know everything that light is made of
particles because we can take a very
sensitive instrument that makes clicks
when light shines on it and if the light
gets dimmer the clicks remain just as
loud there are just fewer of them thus
light is something like raindrops each
little lump of light is called a photon
okay
i want to emphasize that light comes in
as form particles you were probably told
something about light behaving like
waves i'm telling you the way it does
behave like particles light is made of
particles
i hope you understood that okay uh what
is mr feinman going to talk about he's
going to talk about particles
he's not going to talk about waves he
doesn't like waves he's going to say
light is particles
but with particles he says yeah it gives
us absurd
explanation no kid
i wonder why well we'll find out okay
hold your horses here it goes you might
wonder how it is possible to detect a
single photon one instrument that can do
this is the photo multiplier by the way
i used photomultiplier at amd so i'm at
least i'm very familiar with it and i
discussed that in the past and all i can
tell you is the following photo
multiplier is designed to detect any
blip any
thump as a particle
and maybe that's where the problem is
because it's designed that way to count
bumps or or blips or whatever and
immediately converts that to a particle
and that's the so-called photon okay
that's what i want you to keep in mind
when a photon hits the metal plate okay
so we're done we know it's a photon it's
a particle now he's going to talk about
hitting
okay he thinks something is traveling
that's a photon this green photon is
going to hit
okay the metal plate a at the bottom it
causes an electron to break loose from
one of the atoms in the plate and again
he's making a second assumption which is
the electron is another particle which
the photon hits
you wonder how that is possible first
because the photon is zero dimensional
so is the electron they have no size and
here the photon has such great aim that
it's going to hit an electron
that's rolling around in different
places around the energy level or
orbital
and it's going to hit it
man that's that's quite a
important photon that it can hit an
electron first they're both zero
dimensional then it's got tremendous aim
because it's going to hit that electron
okay
to break loose from one of the atoms in
the plate the free electron knocks loose
even more electrons so we have now a
cascade
okay a chain reaction the electron
knocks more electrons this process is
repeated 10 or 12 times until billions
of electrons what are you talking about
current a sizable electric current hit
the last plate each time a photon of a
given color hits the photomultiplier a
click of uniform loudness is heard
okay
so that's again because the multiplier
has been designed to detect any thump as
a particle it's already done and so they
say see uh
light is full of particle is made of
particles because the photomultiplier is
detecting them no no it's that the photo
multiplier was designed to consider
every little signal every little thump
or whatever
um as a particle
that's the problem okay
okay so uh let's see how he explains
reflection again mr finally now is going
to work his way to explaining
the mechanism when a photon comes down
it interacts with electrons throughout
the glass not just on the surface the
photon and electron do some kind of
dance the net result of which is the
same as if the photon hit only the
surface
96 of the surface of the glass is holes
that let the light through while the
other four percent of the surface is
covered by small spots of reflective
material
an average of four percent of the
photons hitting a single surface of
glass is reflected
with a second surface the results are
strange it's
instead of the expected reflection of
eight percent you know four from one
surface four from another
by the two surfaces the partial
reflection can be amplified as high as
16 percent
or turned off depending on the thickness
of the glass
okay so what is he saying we've got two
surfaces
if you look at just one surface and you
look at the holes
and these regions he says uh
96 percent of them is holes and just
goes through but there's four percent
that bounce back
from the surface now you have a second
surface
for for that glass and now you would
expect to have twice the four percent
you would have four percent at the top
four percent of the bottom
when they do the experiments uh usually
sixteen percent it goes down to zero
depending on the thickness of the glass
so now that's what they got to explain
and so um the first attempt is to
explain it with waves transverse waves
maxwell james maxwell he came up with
uh equation for waves uh
mr augustine uh
friend now
uh had already proposed the transverse
wave okay
earlier this strange phenomenon of
partial reflection by two surfaces can
be explained for intense light by a
theory of waves this is what he's saying
okay he's telling you they can explain
waves but the wave theory cannot explain
how the detector makes equally loud
clicks as the light gets dimmer and he's
got this little footnote there he says
this idea made use of the fact that
waves can combine and cancel out and the
calculations based on this model match
the results of newton's experiments
as well as those done by hundreds of
years after for hundreds of years
afterwards but when instruments were
developed that were sensitive enough to
detect a single photon the wave theory
predicted that the clicks of the
photomultiplier would get softer and
softer whereas they stayed at full
strength they just occurred less and
less often no reasonable model could
explain this fact okay you see what the
problem is they say the wave can explain
the mechanism but the wave cannot
explain the clicks of the
photomultiplier that's essentially his
argument
and that's because there is no such
physical object as a wave
but with a rope
we're talking about each link
that's a photon there
that's a photon
and the last link the one that's
connected to the atom right there okay
it's constantly torquing as the atom
expands and contracts and eats
into that link
and then releases
each releases each releases
okay and that's the something that they
count as a particle
when it's really a rope extending from
atom to atom that's what we're proposing
in exchange so now we don't have the
wave problem of
little blips there
we can detect them with the photosensit
uh photo multiplier
except that we gotta make a change and
not use the wave now we're gonna use a
rope a physical object a wave is not a
physical object there's no such physical
object called a wave in science let
alone in physics
okay so uh what does uh
mr finally concluded he says quantum
electrodynamic resolves this wave
particle duality by saying that light is
made of particles
he solved it okay uh but the price of
this great advancement of science is a
what a retreat by physics to the
position of being able to calculate only
the probability that a photon will hit a
detector without offering what a good
model of how it actually happens
as mr feynman explained
uh reflection
now he says
like he started out he ended up with how
he started he says we can't explain it
but we're going to do it with particles
no matter what because light is
particles we're done
and anyone who wants to get the
microphone has to work with mic with
particles he can't work with
a rope
okay so he's already denying me
the ability or the uh opportunity to
speak
he's already censored me he's saying
it's particles and we're going to
continue with particles we can't explain
anything with a particle but we're going
to say that lightest particles
that's what they're saying okay
okay um
how does he end his presentation he is
this this is interesting he says the
situation today is we haven't got a good
model to explain partial reflection by
two surfaces we just calculate the
probability that a particular
photomultiplier will be hit by a photon
reflected from a sheet of glass right
he's gonna describe
you will have to brace yourselves for
this not because it is difficult to
understand but because it is absolutely
ridiculous
all we do is draw little arrows on a
piece of paper that's all
well i like the fact that at least he
was honest and told it like it was you
know they have no clue whatsoever
that's the point so don't ask them
questions that they can't answer ask
them questions that they can that's what
they're saying
and mathematical physics cannot answer
explanations they cannot answer physical
interpretations
not because they're non
sensical or uncommon sensical it's
because they do they use it particles
that's the problem okay okay and uh here
we have uh
because you might say well final said
that in 1960s we should have made some
progress since then right okay let's
find out here we have mr maddow dowd
okay and he uh works for uh pbs i call
him bs okay
and he's going to try to
resolve the issue between the copenhagen
interpretation of quantum mechanics the
many worlds and the bone wave and so on
he says we're now approaching 100 years
since the discovery of quantum mechanics
and we still don't know which of these
which of those three you know the
copenhagen or the many worlds etc
versions of quantum mechanics and we
still don't know which of these if any
are right okay so what's the hold up
okay what is the hold up a clue to the
problem lies in the word interpretation
okay
an interpretation of quantum mechanics
is exactly that it's a story about what
really happened what's really happening
behind the math
what a physical mechanism give what
physical mechanism give rise to the
equations of quantum mechanics yeah
that's what we want to know but mr
feynman already finished telling us that
they don't know that stuff
and here mr o'dowd says and the fact is
that every prominent interpretation of
quantum mechanics is perfectly
consistent with the equation that lies
at the heart of the theory
uh what do you mean it's consistent you
mean uh you can describe it not that you
can explain it
and he says that's the schrodinger
equation
well an equation can only describe it
you know we're not talking about an
explanation so this guy doesn't
he he went off on to the you know on a
tangent to left field because we're
asking for an explanation he says that
what is an explanation or a physical
interpretation and he says he wants to
know the physical mechanism and then he
talks about a description
and he says the stroke in your equation
what describes
how the wave function of a quantum
system changes over space and time and
so it should completely determine the
measurements we can make of that quantum
system
he's not talking about a theory a theory
is an explanation
theory is not a description which is
what mr o'dowd is referring to
so again to this day they don't have an
explanation
and
what you see out there usually something
like this you'll see it done with
particles okay there you see light a
little photon hitting
the surface of glass or whatever surface
it's hitting and they say that's what
reflection is
the particle just hits bounces off
that's their explanation
okay and so what's the problem with this
well um
there's too many problems to consider
but let me look at one uh by mr don
lincoln
and he's the guy who works for fermilab
he does uh
some of these same shows
he does it for herme lab trying to
explain what the quantum mechanics don't
know okay because again they don't know
they're going to describe and this is
what he says this is uh out of his uh
presentation and you see you get this uh
light coming to a
an interface between for example in this
case air and glass and you have a
reflection coming back up but in order
to explain this he's going to use these
positive and negatives there to the
right which are supposedly the atoms
okay so they're going to be rearranged
there you'll see that in a second okay
and
you can see that the negatives and
positives you know arrange themselves in
such a way that allows uh a reflection
what's the problem with this well the
problem is those positive and negatives
uh there is no such thing as positive
and negative in uh in
physics there's only positive and
negative in mathematics what does
positive and negative mean in physical
terms
and we go back to you know where where
we are with uh the atom what does an
atom look like and this is their atom
this is their positive and negative the
negative is the blue ball they're going
around the positive is that black uh one
in the center that's got the quarks
being uh held together by so-called
gluons
they throw gluons at each other but
they're held together who knows
what that means and they always
paint them with uh
bed springs you know held together i
don't know
what a bedspring looks like because i've
never seen it in the standard model okay
and what is current because he's going
to talk about you know
electromagnetism
which involves uh the atom and the atom
according to them is a little ball again
it goes around the atom there you see
the little red balls in this case going
on uh from one atom to another and this
flow is what's called electricity and
again all they have to answer they have
to illustrate is their atom
and if mr lincoln cannot illustrate his
atom he doesn't have a case
he doesn't have a physical
interpretation okay that's what i'm
saying he's going to use positive and
negatives he's talking about
descriptions again mathematical
descriptions not physical
interpretations
so his
so-called explanation is bunk
bunk not because
um
in other words it's not the explanation
we're criticizing it's his assumptions
he doesn't have an atom he doesn't have
a photon he doesn't have an electron
that's the problem until he can settle
that you know and
show us what his atom looks like he
doesn't have a case he can't even start
to talk we have to remove the microphone
from his mouth and he's got to go back
to the drawing board erase it completely
and start brainstorming again
okay what's the uh rope version of
reflection very straightforward uh
kindergartener can understand it okay
there you see it
you have rope connected from adam to
adam uh so there's a rope coming from
one atom we're just looking at one rope
one atom and we're talking about
something so so small so so thin
okay and so you gotta ponder that here
you're looking at something that atom
man would be looking at and the rope is
very thick there it's much thinner than
that okay so keep all this in mind but
the point is that light travels back and
forth along the rope because uh it
torques and it stimulates both atoms the
ones that are at either end of that rope
if the glass is thick or has a different
material in it so that it's not
completely pure
uh or it's a crystal so that it's um
crystal structure is organized in some
um you know meaningful way
then you might have differences in the
wavelength throughout the glass
okay so you might have that situation
there and again that's got to do with
the rope the fact that frequency is um
inversely proportional to wavelength
okay
and
the more you have one the less you have
of the other under the rope model and
it's very simple to understand you know
you have the rope the more you torque it
okay
for the same amount of rope you have
more links and each link is shorter
that's what frequency and wavelength the
inverse proportion of frequency and
wavelength uh indicate and you know
light travels at 300 000 kilometers per
second
uh it's a constant so little c is a
constant and it's equal to the inverse
relation between frequency and
wavelength in our case
number of links times link length
very straightforward a baby can
understand it okay we're not talking
about
uh
what is it
something beyond your capability okay
okay and uh here you see what happens
with a prism and when you do it with
waves you can't explain it what can we
explain with a transverse wave well when
it goes through a prism you know that
when the light comes out like if you put
white light coming in and what comes out
is color light as mr newton showed well
uh you know that those uh different
wavelengths that come out with different
colors they have different uh lengths in
other words they have different wave
lengths okay
and how do you get that from a prism if
the prism squashes for example right
squash is the wave so that you have
either smaller or bigger
waves going through there how does that
wave later on get bigger or smaller when
it goes back out to air for example
see this is what you gotta explain with
with the wave nature of light assuming
you could explain the wave you can see
that the wave is wet a bunch of vectors
so what what you what you're staring at
there is something very scary you're
having mathematical vectors which are
moving they're not only moving up and
down but they're moving sideways
very scary stuff okay
under the rope model uh we can explain
that very easily here you see the rope
model okay we have white light coming in
again it's a different frequencies of
different wavelengths you put them all
together you get white light what
happens when you get inside the prism
you have
atoms which are connected to different
atoms on the other edge
and
the one that gives you red has longer
lengths and the one that gives you blue
or violet you know and the bottom the
shorter links
very simple and why because those are
connected to another atom that's outside
the picture okay that's the issue and
again we're only showing one atom here
really in reality you're talking about
gazillions of atoms okay but there you
can see why we have colors coming out of
a prism and again for reflection very
simple because light travels both uh
torsion the torsion travels in both
directions
uh between two atoms so both atoms
receive the signal simultaneously and
permanently and constantly okay so it's
it's no mystery okay it's really no
mystery at least you can understand it
whether you believe it or not that's a
separate issue that's your personal
opinion what we're talking about here is
being able to
visualize a mechanism and everybody
should be able to visualize
a rope torquing
and sending signals these bumps to both
atoms which are expanding and
contracting and torquing the rope okay
so this is essentially what we're
proposing
what should we conclude okay let's go
with the conclusions to wrap it up okay
here it is conclusions quantum
mathematicians
confess that they have no rational
explanations or physical interpretations
for reflection okay mr feinman was clear
about that the other two
mr o'dowd mr lincoln
uh they do hocus-pocus they cannot
explain it they immediately move into
descriptions not into explanations
because they cannot explain it
especially with discrete particles okay
and again you can see that they bring in
the wave when mr uh
finder says there is no such thing as a
wave
light is particles
okay he tells you that but these guys
say well let's bring in the waves so
that we have this duality and we can
sneak around you know
the the the particle because the
particle with that they cannot explain
it
this is due in part because quantum
mechanics doesn't have a physical model
of the atom specifically the electron or
of a photon you simply cannot explain
perfectly straight rectilinearly
rectilinear behavior right whichever of
the two extends straight moves
rectilinearly okay
of light in other words reflection with
discrete particles that's the big
problem
okay
under the rope model proposes that light
propagates bi-directionally along a
dna-like rope that connects two atoms
which are pumping back and forth doing
their quantum jump twerking the rope
so it's a self-stimulating system
the atoms uh go back and forth expand
eat
the first link then release it
and that stimulates the other atom which
is doing the same thing to the rope in
the opposite direction so both atoms are
receiving a this thump this photon that
the multi photo multiplier counts as a
particle okay that's that's what's
happening
and so with the rope uh we don't have
the same problem that mr feynman showed
that uh you won't get the blips on the
photo multiplier yes you will because
again we're talking about that little uh
piece of rope that is thumping the atom
constantly that's that's the thump that
the photo multiplier is detecting the
model illustrates
reflection okay
do you believe it well that's a separate
issue you know belief we don't deal with
that in science we just explain
objectively so that you understand
whether you believe or not is your
personal opinion
okay let's go with the questions and
comments people made and we had a few
flat earthers come over and visit us
okay
let's see what they have to say here we
have one it says you got to re uh
research on flat earth
for me it's incredible there's still
flat earth there's a reinvented flat
earth
again it looks like the flat earth
society was dying but some came out and
reinvented it
you know resuscitated it
uh what can i say
um
here's uh
if you want to know you know i mean this
is important okay because
these people claim that if you go if you
were to go to the uh um
antarctica
you know down to the south pole
you if you would go there you would find
that there's this wall of ice
they say okay why don't we go there
let's find out
let's find out that there's this wall
around
you know the flat earth right like you
see there
you know the
what what you see on the edges of that
circle that's supposed to be ice
according to the flat earthers
it's okay it's very simple we can prove
it right let's just go there and find
out and see if there's a wall of ice all
around the earth right very simple
and they say you can't oh why can't we
well we said because you have all these
soldiers that won't let you go
and be able to see this okay it's all
these damn soldiers i guess most of them
are american soldiers the national guard
or who knows about and they're guarding
all that ice so that you won't find out
the truth that's their explanation for
that
okay so i'm sorry i cannot um study the
flat earth because the national guard
will not allow me to
not allow me to prove whether there's a
wall of ice surrounding the flat earth
okay
another flat earther comes in there says
oh i think it's the same one study says
study
uh taurus fields okay so i looked up
these taurus fields that's what you see
when you put up taurus fields
and i was saying what the hell am i
staring at what are these few what is it
that's moving there
i need to know please stop it i want to
see
one field and find out what that field
is you know don't make it roll by i want
to see a static image so that i know
what i'm staring at once i'm staring at
you have to identify and tell me what
i'm staring at
until then all we have is something in
motion that nobody understands and yeah
there is no such thing as a field in
science
uh the word field belongs strictly to
religion okay so anyone using the word
field is doing religion what is a field
according to the mathematicians of value
at each point in space it's math it's
just numbers that's what a field is just
values that they measure like the
strength of uh magnetic or gravitational
field
there is no physical object field it's
just a measurement here a measurement
there they put all that together all
these numbers together and they say if
you get farther away from the earth uh
gravity becomes weaker that's it and
that
whole system of measurements around the
earth where you can say well this is
what gravity is here here here and here
all that is called a field
there is no physical object called field
field is a bunch of numbers that the
mathematicians need to know what the
strength of the field is at a given
point further from an object that's it
so there is no physical object called
field you can't use the word field to
say the field did this
no no you can't use that not in science
that's in religion
you can't give a physical interpretation
using the word field
okay another fellow uses uh says
something else he says for gravity he
found out what gravity is he says things
fall due to dielectric acceleration not
gravity
okay so you look it up and find out that
there are at least five flat earth
explanations for gravity
and there's one that it's magnets the
other one says that it's density you
know one object is denser than another
they have all these versions in
in flat earth land
all the flatlanders okay
and this guy subscribes to the third one
dielectric acceleration objects fall due
to the difference of electrical charges
between earth and heavens
and there's one guy who ran an
experiment
which was uh
put out there by a fellow in argentina
who
criticized me and i went back and
criticized him and this is more or less
what he put up there he says look this
has this little piece of paper and it's
originally on the top you'll see that in
a second there it's at the top and now
he's going to
release the
electricity on the top and he says look
it falls to the ground to
uh the negative pole and he says that
this is how
gravity really works he says the earth
is negative okay and so everything falls
to the negative pole okay and so he
thinks it's electricity
and there's too many problems with that
the first one being that no one has
defined no one in mathematical physics
or the electric universe or any of those
religions no one has defined what
electricity is in fact the
electric universe starts by saying that
they don't have any clue what
electricity is
and their title is electric universe
so they don't know what electricity is
that i've talked about that in the past
and so these people start off on the
wrong foot already they say look we
don't know what electricity is but
gravity is electricity
great
so how does it do it i mean if
if negative pulls on that little piece
of paper fine
how does it do it physically
what physical entity is in contact with
the paper that pulls it down to the
bottom that's what we want to know
okay so because they say negative pulls
on the paper
great no problem how does it do it from
a distance
i don't see or touch anything in between
the plate on the bottom and the paper
what touch the what compelled the paper
that little piece of paper to fall to
the ground
that's what they have to explain and of
course we don't have an explanation for
that from the flat earth society okay
okay another flat earther comes in there
says for someone with so much
intelligence you really can't see a way
for satellites to be going around above
the earth flat earth
what do we use what do we use a water
level for bill
and another fellow says the spinning
ball earth belief again come on
okay so one of the issues that these
flat earthers have they always bring the
subject up i've explained it a million
times they keep asking the same thing so
i i think that they never come back to
find out what i said i'm sure they could
not repeat what i said in their own
words okay they cannot and so i this is
only for intelligent people not for flat
earthers okay
the earth is a sphere
okay
and you say why is it a sphere bill how
can you curve water which is what's on
their mind all the time they say well
you can't curve water because when i go
to the bathtub uh the water is flat
okay and when i go to the ocean it looks
flat to me you know that's the way they
decide all these things
and so we have to look at the earth and
you can see there i put a round earth
sorry guys i had to put a round earth
there to explain what i've got to
explain that round is uh two-dimensional
but keep in mind it's three-dimensional
sphere okay so it is a sphere it's
globular you know
and so what's the issue there well
the only way you can explain gravity is
that
with a rope model okay every atom is
connected to all other atoms
okay and so you see one atom there it's
connected to all other atoms that make
up the earth the other one is also
connected to all atoms on earth and the
one on the bottom is also connected to
all atoms on earth so where are they all
pulling towards the center of the earth
so every atom on earth is pulling
towards the center because that's where
most of the matter is as you go outwards
you know you find
uh fewer
fewer levels
more levels but i mean what you have is
more atoms and they're all pulling in
the direction of the center
and when you get to water same thing and
there i put air as well why the air
stays around the earth
because every atom of the air
remember every atom is connected to
every other atom
every atom of the air is being pulled
towards the center of the earth now use
the word pull when that's not the case
but just to make my case every atom of
the air is tied to
every atom in the center of the earth
so that's why all celestial objects are
spherical
that's why they're all celestial objects
have gravity because they're all pulling
towards the center and that's why it's
roundish that's why it's spherical okay
so water does curve
because the way you produce water not
not in a little level like this guy
thinks and i'm not going to show it that
way you got to look at the whole ocean
why the ocean curves the ocean curves
because every atom that makes up the
ocean is being pulled towards the center
of the earth that's why water occurs
around the earth
okay got it flat earther okay
now they won't because they'll ask the
same question next time around they'll
say oh huh how do you curve water how do
you curve air you know now i just
explained it to you you don't understand
well if you got a mental problem okay
you got to see a psychologist not a
physicist
okay another fellow raises a question
says if the rope model is correct should
everything be transparent
okay that's a cheap shot because uh this
is like asking a quantum mechanic okay
is if the particle model is correct
should everything be transparent
i mean where does he get this idea that
should everything be transparent at
least if he should go in there it would
be transparent because of
this so first he's got to explain why uh
with particles
it wouldn't be transparent
okay
everything should be transparent with
particles as well and with waves and
with anything
i mean
please explain why you think everything
should be transparent
so we don't know what's going on through
his tiny brain okay
then he continues how can a sheet of
aluminum foil
stop light yet an inch of glass cannot
yeah how come
okay how does the wave model of light
explain how does the particle model of
light explain it in quantum mechanics
i mean if if
don't ask
don't ask what your country can do for
you that's what you can do for your
country you know uh go in there and
explain it with whatever you want
quantum mechanics particles waves
whatever you got before you ask the
question
because he's asking a question we've
already answered in in because that's
where he came from last um
the last uh lecture
and so all he's got to do is look at the
lecture and find out what the problem
with quantum mechanics is what and why
we can explain it with a rope model but
he's asking the same question so please
explain first with particles then come
over here and ask for
an explanation from the role model
and as he says does metal stop rope
vibrations
i don't know what vibrations he's
talking about the rope torques
okay it doesn't vibrate like up and down
this is not what happens with the rope
some vibration like that okay just in
case
and again uh sometimes people don't do
enough
listening
and they jump to the they hear it rob
[Music]
okay well why this you know at least
instruct yourself what the rope model is
about there's a book out there it's for
free you download it read it you'll find
out a lot of information then you can
ask questions but if you haven't even
done a minimum
of research you're not going to
understand squad of what i explained to
you because you know nothing about the
rope you haven't even taken the trouble
knowing the basics so there's a minimum
you know there's a book out there it's
for free you can download it read it
then you can say okay bill why this why
that this guy hasn't done that hasn't
done a minimum
of reading okay that's where he should
start
okay um fellow says
an object looks transparent because
light waves pass through unchanged
no that's not why it's transparent and
that's not quantum what quantum says and
no one says that okay so please get that
off your head it's not transparent
because uh light waves go through it
because you haven't explained why or how
light waves go through it to begin with
you can't just state that and say it you
got to say why
why does uh like why does uh why do
light waves just go through it
uh what they they're ghosts or um uh
souls uh spirits what are they
so you gotta explain that or right if
it's a mathematical
mathematical concept yeah i guess that
can go through anything because there's
no physical object called wave period
we're done okay so you can't use the
word wave
again you see a wave down at the bottom
one of those i showed it last time bunch
of vectors that's all you're staring at
what is a vector it's a
mathematical concept that has
supposedly
uh magnitude and direction
the light in other words it moves in a
given direction that's what we're saying
there right but it can't move because a
vector doesn't move because a vector is
a number and numbers don't move we're
done period
vertices cephei
the light wave effectively passes
through unchained yeah you gotta explain
that okay
just stating it doesn't make it true
as a result we can see straight through
almost a as though the object isn't even
there yeah but you can explain that all
you're doing is uh hand waving you're
doing a magic black magic you're saying
it is so
because we saw it in the
in the lab well you didn't see the wave
because obviously there is no physical
object called wave you didn't see it
with particles because uh they say
particles are zero dimensional and mr
feinman just finished saying that they
cannot explain anything with the
particles and so you can't explain it
can't explain it with either waves or
particles so uh all you're doing is just
uh state making statements
unsubstantiated statements that's all
you're doing there
where is both an action
okay and what
what something is doing a verb yeah okay
and an object
that we detect interact with that we can
measure three dimensionally now there is
no physical object called wave there you
see it at the bottom it's a bunch of
vectors what's a vector it's a number
that's all it is it's a mathematical
number there's no physical object called
a mathematical number the number five is
not a physical object okay sorry
wave has shape no
no concept has shape
wave is a concept
especially when it moves
it's an abstract concept it's a ghost
no such monster as a wave okay
uh
ocean ocean waves that's water
so the object is water h2o whatever you
want to call it atoms molecules
wave is what it does so you can't say
the wave did this now what did it is the
atom that's moving like a wave that's
the correct way of stating it in physics
in science
okay um
says
what is the rope mechanism for opacity
opacity and transparency and refraction
uh i explained transparency in that last
video just check it out and you'll see
what transparency is okay again people
ask questions that have been answered in
the in the video you can ask a specific
question
uh what you didn't understand about
transparency but it's in the it's in the
uh discussion there so i have no idea
why these people
ask these questions when it was covered
okay and it looks like they don't read
they don't watch i don't know what
they're doing
okay
uh phil says uh
isn't uh
aren't gas liquid also non-objects uh
they're defined in terms of molecular
motion
no object in science is defined
in terms of motion okay let's get that
straight
what is a gas
gas is what you can point to and you
better not see that gas moving okay
objects are defined in terms of motion
only in the religion of mathematics
mathematical physics in science the word
object is defined statically okay
meteorology what something is made of is
outside the bounds of science and parts
of whole temporal parts which is what
this fellow is referring to
also belong exclusively to mathematics
okay
no you if you you got to be able to
point
that's an object
uh
there's got to be a shape in front of
you okay
it doesn't have to move okay and it
should not be dependent on anything else
uh if god made a single triangle in the
universe
uh on a flat sheet of paper or whatever
maybe did it by magic just a triangle
there floating in space no thickness
that's an object it has shape okay
uh no medium no whatever you don't have
to understand it completely all i'm
saying is god made a two-dimensional
triangle in the middle of space and he
just put it there it has shape
has no width no thickness
[Music]
and that's an object and it's not
dependent on anything i don't need
another object in the in the field of
view to understand what a triangle is he
points he says triangle i understand the
word it refers to that
trilateral thing that's in front of me
that's it
that's what an object is in science
that's how we present it
it's not see or touch criteria okay uh
fella says hassam felder ass referring
to sabine hassenfelder she made a new
video says are we made of math
i think she is crazy she says well i
talked about that the other day but let
me put this up here first
fellow says you don't know about the
world uh word
about the world exist and i think you're
saying the word existence existence is
not the reduction of the reality on
matter okay i don't know what that is
existence means put out i don't know
what that is either so let's answer uh
both because uh sabine essentially
discussed the word exist in that video
that she put out and i talked about it
the other day let me put this over here
and what she said is ah did you see uh
well this is what a guy said says are we
made of math and she said in physics
something is real because it's a good
explanation for our observations no
that's not what real or exist mean okay
you have to define the word exist in
physics because physics is the science
of existence
what is the existence for both uh sabine
and this other fella
somebody was trying to be funny only
that's why she said we are made of math
but she talked about existence what do
you mean by exists and she's got it
completely wrong
she said existence is what uh a good
explanation for our observations no
that's not what exists means in physics
or in any in science so she's got that
wrong and of course if she's got that
wrong she's got everything else wrong
no exist means physical presence means
an object that has location
once you get that you can explain many
things because now you can use the term
um consistently rationally
scientifically
okay
okay um
another fellow says
bill you haven't talked about let's say
push gravity yet i did really i talked
about it in the past uh a long time ago
now probably a year
and all i'm going to say is the
following year
okay uh push gravity has been around for
a long time you could credit mr
lucretius uh maybe he was one of the
first ones to mention it in a roman
um you know get to that in a second but
uh more formally before the sage we have
mr nicholas fascio uh he invented the
shadow theory of gravitation he never
published it formally but he wrote
letters lots of letters on that mr
lesage apparently got it uh individual
you know he discovered it or came up
with it
by himself but he came
with it 50 years later so um
i think with the credits should be going
to mr fascio
that's up to everyone to decide that but
we had all kinds of people in the 19th
century had a lot of people deal with
that among them james maxwell 1920s mr
majorana he ran a gravitational
absorption experiment which he said he
proved
that gravity is this shadow mechanism
uh mr casimir hendrick kassimer he
applied it to
electromagnetism
and another fella i'm going to mention
tom van flandern within which i had a
little head butting before he died
and he championed the push gravity you
know push gravity
and so
push gravity has been around for a long
time and what are they referring to
they're saying there's the shadow
phenomena okay and if you know the
casimir effect it'll give you an idea
you have two plates okay
and they're saying that they're pl the
plates are attracted
and the
response to that is that there's
particles pushing the two plates
together what's holding them apart are
the particles in between once you remove
the particles in between you know
you have that shadow effect where
the particles on the outside push them
together and that's what gravity is
gravity is according to these people
something that's blocking the particles
and when you remove that something now
the particles are free to go and push
you towards the earth
that's their explanation
uh
[Music]
should i address that well maybe in the
future i'll address it again but
it's uh
it's a a murder you know to try to tell
a guy who believes in particles that
there are no such things as particles
and that the particles cannot explain
gravity here's uh mr lucretius i just
pulled a um
a little
sample from his uh book he wrote this
book the rerum natura
and in book two you'll find something
like this which you can say is maybe the
first
notion of this shadow
theory of gravity okay
and says things about through voi about
true void the first beginnings of things
must all move on either by their weight
or happily by stroke of another during
motion they have met and clashed the
result is a sudden rebounding in an
opposite direction and no wonder since
they are most hard and of white
proportion to their solidity and nothing
behind gets in their way
well anyways you can read through this
later on and essentially
you could say that mr lucretius was the
first one to propose this shadow theory
of gravity depending on how you
interpret his words you can look up book
two of the rare
natura
and he explains it in more detail in
other paragraphs there uh again this
idea has been around for a long time the
shadow okay
it's bunk
that's all i can tell you not worth even
considering it okay anyone dealing with
particles has to have a mental problem
anyone who talks about the ether as a
mental problem because if after 10 000
years you cannot explain anything with
the so-called ether with this bunch of
particles
we should have erased it from the board
a long time ago
lived too long and again in general
relativity the ether is known as space
time in quantum mechanics is known as
the false vacuum and they have all these
different versions of the ether there is
no such thing as ether okay a bunch of
particles
okay uh when phil says i can settle for
the rope runs through the electron shell
but i just can't settle for rope runs
through the atomic diameter and he goes
into talking about why he doesn't
believe or has a hard time visualizing
this all i can do is illustrate it for
him here it is
you can imagine these gazillions of
ropes
crisscrossing throughout our space here
because every rope uh ends in an atom
and they also go through to other atoms
which are on the other side of the
universe okay so we have gazillions of
ropes crisscrossing any atom
hopefully they don't stop at the atom
all of them
it's not that every rope stops at an
atom ropes continue to other atoms as
well
so the ropes are very extremely
extremely extremely extremely thin
and small
and an atom is gazillions of times
bigger than a robe let alone how small
an atom is so we're talking about
something so tiny so small so thin
that that's why it probably doesn't have
the ability to be seen or touched
okay so
all i can tell you is yeah the ropes go
right through the atoms only those ropes
that end in that atom
are the ones that make up the atom all
the others go right through
the atom through the diameter
because remember the atom is moving
around anyways going through all those
ropes anyways
and yeah uh
it's the seat touch
that kills everybody everybody says oh
but how can we see how come they don't
touch how come they don't collide how
come they don't bounce
when when the rope meets the rope or
rope meets an atom
c touch is what kills everybody
everybody
is looking for see and touch because
that's our ordinary experience with
everyday things
the ropes don't have the ability to see
or touch okay they can't touch
especially touch
two ropes do not touch each other and
for this you would need to know what the
word touch means first and then it's a
property that the ropes don't have and
of course you can't see a rope because
there's no rope ending in a rope if the
rope ended in a robe you could see the
rope maybe
again we're talking about something
extremely thin and small okay assuming a
rope ended in a rope you still couldn't
see it but there is no rope that ends in
a rope all ropes end in an atom goes
right through the other rope
and when people get into that they say
oh honey you're saying it goes through
through the rope yes it goes through the
rope they don't touch they don't they
don't have the ability to touch each
other and that's the only thing that
kills everybody about
the theory and again it's the only a
real assumption that you have to make
about mother nature's world okay with
quantum you have to make hundreds more
uh assumptions okay and with a rope it's
just that you can't see you're touching
we're not that's how simple it is
okay final comment a
question if a person says how to
communicate across the quantum
multiverse he refers to again mr o'dowd
matt o'dowd who has that pbs space-time
uh slot
and he has this um
uh video he put out the other day uh and
partly partly because he's uh honoring
mr stephen weinberg nobel prize who died
in july now
and so this is more or less what this
video was about and but he talks about
how to
how the
um atoms communicate with other atoms
in the in space there he says you know
that they can communicate faster than
light they give have to give you hope
that we can communicate maybe even
travel faster than light okay they can't
just on the one hand they give
um
credence or you know they they they love
einstein and they say oh he said you
can't travel faster than light and then
on the other they always skirt and go
around and say well but you can't but
see uh if you do this fancy math you can
go faster in light
well the question is it's black or white
either we can't go faster tonight or we
can and if they say that you can't go
faster in light
they create a lot of problems for a lot
of people because that means we can't
even travel to the nearest star
which is four point uh what is it uh
uh 4.5 light years away and round trip
you're talking about 4.3
light years away in round trip
rounding off nine nine years
and so we're never gonna make it to the
nearest star and that
uh creates a problem for people because
it takes hope away from them so they
have to give you some home and they say
oh but but we can under certain
circumstances we can prove it
mathematically
uh travel faster than light
and so that's essentially what he does
here how does he explain it well he this
is more or less his take on that and
he's got these uh things that are
connecting atoms
uh essentially this is entanglement at a
distance
and what are those green uh things which
uh as you can see it's a wave that is
curling around
that straight line
you would wonder what he's talking about
especially the the comet this follow
made and let me put that up there again
essentially he says uh never have seen
this before referring to the ropes right
and so let's show uh mr dowd oh dad
uh what he's really talking about this
is what he's talking about and this is a
bill gate version
yeah he's talking about ropes
okay that's why they're
connected that's that's how you can
explain
action at a distance that's how you can
explain
entanglement okay very simple all you
have to do is
say that you can't see or touch the
physical
mediator it i'll see you next time which
is uh
when on
sunday we'll see you then